je ne crois pas une seconde que tu as la
buav soit celui qu'il prétend être
je n'ai pas cru un mot de ce qu'il a dit
parce que je sais qui il est il dit
qu'il est journaliste et que vous le
voyez dans la marche contre
l'islamophobie
juché sur un camion en train de faire
huer le nom des gens qu'il égrène un par
un est ce que c'est un comportement de
journalistes non c'est un comportement
d'agitateurs il est très connu dans ce
dans cette mouvance islamo-gauchiste je
le répète il est très connu pour son
agitation beaucoup moins pour son
travail de journaliste c'est la première
fois en deux ans que je tweete pendant
une émission de balances ton poste et
j'ai twitté tabac vous prend pour des
cons
il nous a pris pour des cons pendant 40
minutes alors que l'on pouvait pas le
contredire au fur et à mesure bon il a
pu déballer cuisse et un nom brouilleur
de première mais moi voilà il me trompe
pas il ya des millions de français qui
ne trompent pas ils savent qu'il y ait
ce n'est pas un journal c'est un
agitateur c'est un propagateur de
fausses nouvelles on rappelle ce qu'elle
dit christine tout à l'heure il a fait
croire qu'il y avait eu un mort à
tolbiac avec beaucoup de détails donc
c'est quelqu'un qui veut attirer la
lumière albi à tout prix et qui a un
agenda qui est celui maintenant bien
connue de l'islamo gauchisme et
évidemment il a concouru aux élections
sous la bannière de france insoumise
comme par hasard et quand corbières me
dis mais qu'est ce que tu vas me
reprocher l'islamo gauchisme où tu as vu
ça eh ben on vient de le voir on voit ce
que tu sais la france insoumise et
chaque semaine il y aura un truc de plus
une déclaration antisémite puis l'appel
à la décapitation puis le soutien à ben
islamo-gauchiste taabo à poils à la
france insoumise il y aura de plus en
plus haut ou de plus en plus bas et ben
voilà la démonstration
alors il a dit que cette détacher de la
france soumise parce qu'il sent que ça
sent le roussi mérite toujours soutenue
par la france soumise aux par karim
zéribi non non chaque année c'est moi le
respect que j'ai pour eric naulleau mais
je trouve trop dur je trouve pas assez
équilibré eric d'un sauna navigue camion
karine non mais et risque est ce qu'un
journaliste fait ça et journaliste va
dans une manifestation non pas pour
filmer non pas pour écrire mettre sur le
toit d'un camion en 10 ans us celui ci
eut est celui là est ce que c'est un
travail de journaliste
non mais ça n'a pas guéri j'exagère oui
je serais passé bah oui c'est pas non
mais moi je te le dit rick tu as
journalistes militants à bord agitateurs
de 22 ans qui n'est pas passé par les
écoles pour accéder à cette
responsabilité cette fonction qui
c'est jamais bien sûr le tas tout seul
par son militantisme il dit il reconnaît
qu'il a fait des erreurs
c'est un garçon qui avait deux ans il
n'y a pas de faire du militer les gens
après soixante et dix piges ils sont pas
capables de dire qu'ils sont propre une
fois dans leur vie
il dit j'ai reçu ce signal réservé les
frais de santé soit déroulée une île à
ma vie nathan ce midi j'ai fait des
erreurs je dis pas que c'est un enfant
et et qui doit être taxé d'
irresponsabilité
c'est quelqu'un qui à 22 ans il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
qui n'est pas antisémite les images
l'ont démontré qui a été pourtant traité
comme tel j'ai pas dit ça par la rumeur
collective notamment des réseaux sociaux
or dans les images que nous avons vues
il combattait d'antisémitisme et les
propos qui ont été tenus sur les juifs
je n'en ai pas parlé non mais oui mais
on peut pas balayer d'un revers de main
une rumeur qui étaient fondées et qui
tout d'un coup ne l'est plus parce qu'on
dessine effectivement comme cyril la
friterie justement de que d'équilibrer
les choses et nous ici on essaye
effectivement de tout montrer ce qui est
à charge ce qui a des charges même s'ils
ne sont pas un tribunal
or parfois on est mieux montrer que ceux
qui à charge pour cataloguer quelqu'un
pour le caricaturer pour raccourcir ce
qu'il est moi je considère que ce gamin
il a fait des erreurs il en faudra
peut-être encore malheureusement
et quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il
avait appelé au désordre
je considère et qu'il a fait avec son
tweet que nous avons démontré dont on
parle et il a donné un peu logo comme on
dit dans le jargon que certains
reconnaîtront
il a donné le goût donné le go c'est
avoir une responsabilité
donc il peut pas être dénué de
responsabilité sur le tout ce qu'il a
fait parce que quelque part il a rameuté
des militants dont on ne savait pas
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient dans la tête
auprès du pedal public et puis un moment
donné moi je fignole remettons les
choses dans leur contexte et les amis
que le président du milk et pris ses
jambes à son cou pas mais qu'elle est
sujet c'est un homme le prix dans
l'avionique et avec sa femme il entend
des cris des hurlements
il sait pas commis sont dehors il sait
pas s'il ya des jeunes qui qu'ils soient
armés qui sont pas ramer s'ils veulent
du marc hé bien si des excuses au moins
la question sadek al-ahmar pour est-ce
qu'il est parti ce qui n'est pas parti
quand le jeune semble détenir un scoop
and day les parties les parties moins
jeunes il est pas antisémite
il a eu raison de rappeler comme peut
critiquer le gouvernement d'israël sans
être taxé d'anti oui mais
c'est bon parfois de rappeler les
fondamentaux pourquoi parce que le
combat contre l'antisémitisme c'est très
important
c'est trop important pour qu'on le
confonde avec le la critique du
gouvernement on peut critiquer toutes
les religions on nous le rappelle assez
dans notre pays alstom lâche rien de
critiquer toutes les politiques menées
par tulu s'est passé encore jeudi si
nous ne faisons pas au procès à un gamin
qui est un journaliste je le rappelle
engagé il reconnaît donc militants
agitateur à n'en pas douter de 22 ans ne
faisons pas une terroriste
il n'est pas ça mais on a offert ce
n'est pas quelqu'un et 10 dangereux non
mais je voudrais pas que quelqu'un a dit
jeudi que certains peuvent l'affirmer a
ici sur ce plateau
donc lorsqu'il parle de lui pourquoi
parce que dans notre pays on n'a plus le
sens de la mesure
eric tu es un intellectuel le poids des
mots eric s'agissant enfin des noms à la
salle du cinéma même sens à un moment
donné ce n'est pas assez de fascistes 10
à montrouge des lan wang hao à bras
raccourcis excusez moi que zemmour face
ça c'est noah mais pas eric naulleau
pourquoi tu mets le sait moins c'est
parce que j'ai l'impression que tu as
débattre avec est tout de même je ne
sais pas c'est pas que ce jeu je me
faisais moi ça c'est que tout le monde
et chacun sait que tu a formé un duo
avec lui j'aurais aimé kiki qui se
rapproche de toi et pas toi qui te
rapproche de lui céder ce jeune nissan
aux gauchistes je me foutais débat